By adding the meta viewport
tag to the head element of
the page we tell the browser
that we know what we're doing.
We need to use the meta viewport
value with =device-width, which
instructs the page to match the screen's
width in device independent pixels.
This allows the page to reflow
content to match the screen sizes,
whether rendered on a small
mobile device or on the laptop.
Adding the attribute initial-scale=1
instructs the browsers to establish
a one to one relationship between device
independent pixels and CSS pixels.
CSS pixels are what we're used to
working with most of the time, and
really the only one I
need to worry about.
Without initial-scale=1 some
browsers will keep the page width
constant when rotating
to landscape mode.
They also scale the content rather
than allowing it to reflow.